watch out watch out watch out watch out
they're clearing the entire area the
entire area at least on the side street
although I see people up ahead now so I
don't understand what the point of this
charge on the part of the NYPD I was
trying to find my friends sorry
really much
shoved everybody out got shoved into
that corner right there and then they
barricaded when you said I shoved you
out what do they do they came in and
they show just like whip it on without
batons like we were standing there and
like there was like a mob of us and they
were just blue bumping into each other
like this and like holding each other to
make sure that we didn't fall and then
we got in here they're the latest report
okay so it's like four or five rounds of
shoving okay so get more and more and
more violence the most recent one was
people have really resisted an island
camp good news out right before us even
like the legit press they wouldn't even
allow them in there so like to see it
end all the [ __ ] they wouldn't even
allow like that talking about how they
were being tear gas and arrest
and that was the final round